Any tips on avoiding booze?
Yeah,
that's a real tough one.
Well,
I would say a couple of things.
There is a drug.
If you're a binge drinker,
there is a drug called naltrexone that
you could consider and you take
naltrexone every day.
It doesn't really have any psychological
effect on you,
but if you're a nail trucks don't
respond.
Or what will happen is that it will
dampen your positive response to
alcohol.
So some people who are alcoholic,
many of them have a very pronounced
opiate is uh,
an opiate effect from alcohol.
It looks like it's mediated by Beta
endorphin and now trucks into is an
opiate blocker.
And so,
um,
what naltrexone seems to do is dampen
the positive response and the positive
response which would be opiate.
And then dopaminergic is the same
response that makes you want to keep
drinking when you start drinking.
So if you're one of those people that
has a drink and then has to have another
one,
then has to have another one and you
know,
soon all your money's gone.
Then the probability that you have an
opiate response is pretty high.
And now trucks can help with that.
Um,
generally when people take Naltrexone,
nick,
keep drinking,
they try to control but to keep drinking
it and they learn over time that the
alcohol doesn't have the same punch,
still pleasant but doesn't have the same
overwhelming punch than it did at one
point.
So that would be one suggestion.
And it's worth drawing the other reasons
like makeup plan,
I would say do the future authoring
program,
you know,
because it isn't that you're trying to
avoid booze.
Exactly.
It's that you're trying to restructure
your whole life,
you know,
because if you're a drinker than all
your friends are drinkers and,
and you're used to drinking in every
social situation and the places that you
go to socialize or places that you
drank,
tim,
like it's really built in as a whole set
of habits.
And so what you have to do is kind of
redesign your life.
And you have to think of things.
You can't just stop drinking.
You have to figure out what you're going
to start doing instead of drinking.
There's a hole that you have to fill in
and you know the future authoring
program will also helped you figure out
what your life could look like in the
absence of alcohol and what kind of Hell
you could end up being if you keep
drinking and it causes all the problems
that it can cause and I think you really
need to like,
you need to think through the hell that
can occur and you have to think through
how your life could be valuable without
alcohol so that you can be motivated
enough to to try to,
to regulate it.
And I would also say if you fail and
slip,
don't berate yourself and beat yourself
up.
Just start quitting again because you
know if you can cut your alcohol intake
down 75 percent,
that's a hell of lot better than zero.
And often people go all or nothing just
like they do with their quitting
cigarettes and she quit for a month and
then have a cigarette and say,
oh my God,
now I'm now I've broken the pact.
And then they'll smoke a whole pack.
They'd be smoking again.
You don't have to do that.
You can just decide that you slept and
that you're going gonna get back on the
wagon again and now it can take a long
time,
but I do believe that you need a better
vision of life,
right?
You have to find something to do with
it's better than alcohol and that might
take some,
some real consideration,
especially if alcohol is a very potent
drug for you.
Then I would also say don't hesitate to
try the NALTREXONE.
This,
it's got a pretty decent clinical
history and it's basically harmless.
So.